if I want sugar treating in someone put
this in my bag I come back and I've
their house I'm Australian so I've never
actually had candy :
I've only seen it in movies hate it I
think it's it just tastes horrible it
tastes like corn syrup and stripping
paint I think one of the best things
about it becoming fall is that it's
appropriate to buy candy corn without
judgment and there's probably a good
intersection between people that love
candy corn a little brunch yeah the
texture already looks a little weird for
me Oh syrupy oh my gosh that's how you
make it the truth
oh gosh nuts like a Chernobyl tooth
cheese Chloe cheese its chalky eh that's
not the normal candy corn texture
where's the chocolate
there's none he's like pancake batter
really strongly with a little chocolate
aftertaste at first I really tasted the
chocolate and the pancake batter kind of
vibe but then like when when Jim came in
it ruined it it kind of tastes like if
you were to finish a plate of pancakes
leave the plate for like an hour come
back and lick it
fake fruit flavors I was a hard one I'm
just eating it all at once yeah whoa it
was very that like sugary strawberry
flavor where it's not really tasting
like a strawberry at all it's just such
a weird aftertaste like I just want to
like take my tongue out and rub it on
the carpet or something the first taste
immediately is like fake strawberry
almost like medicine but like the good
kind like that pink one that you'd have
on your kid
however after two seconds it really
turns into a waffle
that was crazy I like this one a lot
[Music]
they all smell a little bit like
cleaning solution whoa look just knowing
like French strange this is actually the
least intense flavor you kind this taste
like buttery sweet bread I love it
especially good the taste like butter
that's why I like it I love butter
that was quick easy what a subtle flavor
what's subtle beautiful I'm immediately
going ice bro yeah not even one a
handful I'm on board
would you have any of these over a
classic corn no no way
candy corns are just a candy corn I
don't think we should go beyond those
borders I just feel like with any meal
or lolly if you're gonna eat it it might
as well be worth it right cuz it's not
great for you these who either is brunch
most a time so better be good candy
corns already hard to thin John this is
even harder to binge on the normal candy
yeah um I mean why don't you get another
one